okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest on the channel
torsha
hold up what up
and as you guys know
it is great
rate me mondays where you can call us
what
it can sound so wrong oh but not me not
me i get that all the time you're not
rating me we're rating you today no i
meant like in terms
mind
okay look at it just
your face
it's not funny
hey um
no you're good
okay
um so we're so we're gonna
we're gonna put we're gonna put the
link in the chat
and really got viewers
huh i'm like you actually get viewers i
was like should i pull up the phone
number
i know you you probably get more viewers
on your live streams than i do you're
way more consistent with them to be
honest i'm like not consistent but thank
you
every time i look at your channel you're
always live i'm like i'm i do not go
live yeah i don't do pre-record anymore
oh really yeah
because i rely on them talking to kind
of move things along i know it's weird
because you get like sidetracked and
stuff but when you have social anxiety
you kind of need that
sense of validation a little bit
so i can if there's awkward pauses
otherwise if i record then there's like
two minute long pauses where i stare at
the camera like what the hell was i
saying
that's true and then you have to edit
them out that's too much work
yeah i used to spend all day editing
damn
i can't do it i edit
occasionally i edited the video i posted
today with the nba players dude i was
brian i didn't get through the whole
thing but how many people responded
it was just two
not bad
bro
like
zero
i don't think of them as like people
that respond to girls without the blue
check mark because think about it
it's like how do you know they're real
i don't know but it was funny one of
them i said to my friend oh this one
responded she's like oh i dated him in
high school i was like what
i was like
damn it
i was like what are the odds
like that were they in your area
the knicks
i don't even know sports
oh no i mean
i just don't think nba players are the
best like husbands to be honest
i'm not sure that's like who i wanna i
love how you can figure that out and
brittany runner just like right over her
head like i listen
i just think like if i want to get
cheated on like that's that's where i
should go
right same with rappers
but yeah yeah
did i
click the link
someone did and then they laughed oh
don't be scared yeah guys come on we'll
rate you
um let's talk about something what do
you
what's something uncommon that you find
attractive about men
foreign
[Laughter]
that's what i notice right away forearms
and posture
posture really yeah because i can tell
if you're in the military or not and
that's like the one that freaks me out a
little bit
because of my military guys
yeah
he was in the military he was yeah
oh i was engaged fun fact you were
engaged yeah
what what life have you lived oh crazy
one
wait so you're engaged to this guy
and like what happened what what
happened well i said no
okay i guess he went to my dad to ask
for my hand in marriage and my dad's so
nice and he was like i'm sure she'll
make the right decision
what was wrong with him
um
[Music]
mentally unstable
okay yeah
but
and he didn't pay for anything so
and he kind of moved himself in
oh so it's like a it was like a son
husband yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
so my last my last boyfriend moved in
with my family
yeah honestly
but you guys weren't dating yet right
you're like just
oh that was i forgot that happened too
no it was like
when we first met he stayed at my
family's house for like a week yeah but
then he actually moved in when we were
dating after like a month because he was
getting an apartment and they needed to
put him on the lease so he could get an
id yeah yeah
but that was yeah
sorry i'm messing with body lights
honestly though like
if my parents were cool not that they're
not cool but my mom has like mental
health problems or whatever i would so
do that because then you can see how
they act around family and stuff
yeah it's kind of a big deal if you come
from a family of like a hundred
or giants
oh by the way guys today is torsha's
birthday so put happy birthday to her in
the chat
oh
everyone or your mom happy birthday
so one thing that i think is attractive
about guys that's uncommon is vocal
tonality
that's not uncommon
is it
i just never hear girls talk about it
but a guy with a nice deep voice i'm
like
oh yeah that's how i became attracted
attracted to my ex
my more recent one i guess if you want
to say recent
overview really yeah
voice hell yeah he had a ted talk so hot
yeah it's a huge thing maybe that's why
girls tend to go for men
you know out of their race because they
have deeper voices like baritone
i don't know
i feel the same way about a woman with a
nice deep voice am i weird
yeah a little bit it's typically higher
pitch that men prefer they like the
vocal cry actually do you know that
no what's that
vocal cry um yeah
okay hold on
okay i'm gonna be
kourtney kardashian
and she's just like i
just
want to spend time with my kids
i don't
those go over my boundaries
do you hear it i don't know
no i don't i don't know what you're
doing kind of
like is it like the vocal fry
yeah i say cry
maybe i heard it maybe i heard maybe
that's why i like pearl so much damn
did he just say you have a dude voice
yeah damn
it's okay i have a low voice
who cares [ __ ] him
i think it's annoying do you remember
that show i don't own a tv so i'm gonna
need a lot of help when describing it
but it's the show where they're all in
different apartments and they're texting
it's kind of like the bachelor but on
your phone
anyway so you fall in love that way and
then you meet each other
and
i forget what it's called if anybody
knows it's going to bother me because i
don't know if pearl knows what i'm
talking about but there was this couple
that was a meme and the girl
had this vocal cry baby voice and she
would switch into the baby voice very
often and that's the reason that he was
attracted to her and i was like that's
so annoying like when i want something
and i'm a baby you know
yeah that's odd please
no
and it was
it was a topic for a while
that guys are attracted to that
i was like oh [ __ ] i thought i was being
annoying
yeah
that's another thing
what do you first know most about a guy
other than height
um
smile maybe
like eyes
spies
smile with their eyes
yeah or just like their energy to be
honest but like
[Laughter]
oh yeah i forget that it's true though
it's like the way a guy carries himself
like women can pick up on a lot more
than men can pick up on and
posture
that's why i said it i think posture
and the way that a guy moves kind of
together because when somebody's awkward
their posture is usually like mine right
now where it's kind of like
like hiding yourself and then you have a
guy that just doesn't give a [ __ ] wow my
shoulders are so turned in but they're
just like walking around like
straight and i don't know
i don't know
and then yeah and that kind of goes to
their confidence too like how they hold
carry themselves
that's
why that stuff isn't really taught
though like i have very awkward body
language me too
it's very like i kind of humorous um
yeah i kind of wish it was like taught
like it would have been something that
had been good to learn
i don't think you're that awkward to be
honest with you i actually think you're
more extroverted
oh i am
but it's like um
just like where do you put your hands
type [ __ ]
it's like okay when i take a picture i
like don't know what to do with my body
i'm like no one does
no
always create your hair um if you're
gonna take a picture with a girl most
girls will do the hip thing what i do is
i do it in the back though and then
you're kind of like forced into like a
comfortable more comfortable position
where i just avoid photos and hopefully
it's
uh
facing you so you can see
but i don't think you're awkward at all
i think you just think you're awkward
i think
i still think i'm awkward
nobody that's actually awkward is how
would go to like the pua thing like that
takes balls
just saying oh i'm ballsy but like
awkward people could still be ballsy
i'm just bold so you're saying that you
have awkward mannerisms without the
anxiety yeah that's crazy to me yeah
like
yeah like like
i don't care like i'm awkward and i just
don't care but you can't
when you watch my videos that's why
people think of buddies because i'm kind
of awkward
yeah
yeah that's what that's what that's like
that entertainment value true
yeah just awkward i never really noticed
it yeah and i just don't or maybe like
i don't know
like i don't know i don't think
like i think you're more anxious than
awkward to be honest but maybe it's just
because you're really hot
like respectfully just don't like when
people
turn from what they're doing to look
it's always okay i just it's even though
i know that people will just look and
like look back i just don't like it
i don't know why
it's like i should be flattered
but it's been like that since i was like
13 so it's kind of like
gross
and to be honest with you
oh my gosh you think anyone's gonna call
in
we'll see you you had you had him so
quick on your show
i'll share it hold on um
i'll tell rolo
one rolo shows happens
[Laughter]
oh my
i forgot
hold up hold up
yeah that's probably how people will see
it and then i'll tell them
it's okay i'm chilling
my phone's gonna die hold on
let's see
what's up for me
should i make a new thumbnail make it
poppin
maybe they're scared
let me and wait hold on i'm trying to
change the title um
you're chilling
can you hear my dog
no actually
well i have a less
powerful mic i got a new one oh yeah you
told me the s wait not the sm7b but the
s
m7 or something
the one tony said to get
yes
yeah is calling
that's why the font is green not a good
color
[Music]
i don't know
only when you're talking about bitcoin
oh really i don't
i hate thumbnails okay
sometimes i'm into making them but
then my neck is just messed up for days
let me do
i'm like going back and fixing a lot of
my videos is what i've been doing lately
and like re-posting some of the old ones
did people notice
i feel like what the audience would
be scared they would notice what that i
reposted videos and get mad
oh they'd get mad no i just i it's like
a clip like i post oh yeah they like
that exactly yeah like i post instead of
a um
a full length
yeah
i'm gonna take lazy because then it's
more thumbnails dude it's the thumbnails
i think that's like annoying
because yeah that's why mine are bad
what's your what's your engagement rate
on the thumbnails like your
question
i think it
that's the number that i have no idea
hold on
is that the c
p m
or is that something else where do i go
analytics um
oh you don't it's um
i never really look to be honest oh
really oh i thought you were all on
i've looked once
no like i'll look once a month and then
kind of forget about it until
kareem
kareem keeps up with me
hold on do i go to audience
uh hold on hold on you go to
impressions
it's hold on
let me find it i think it's under
overview if i just look a second
oh you have to go to
the dashboard oh it's
oh i thought i had it i don't know i
have a 50
click-through rate
oh that's great
50 percent
eighty 884 thousand forty one point six
hold on
oh it's it's um impressions click
through rate that's what it is
so five point one percent so forty one
point six percent from youtube
recommending your content
five point one percent click through
rate oh that's your click through okay
that's what i was asking because i was
like 50 that's insane
so you should be millions 41.6
so for well it is it is kind of like
that it's like if there's
about
40 percent
more than 40
so for every impression 40 of the time
they click on it that's great
but do they stay i think that's the
click-through rate
question um
okay
smash or pass i'm going to do men in the
manosphere for you
oh god
okay
smasher pass um
myron
why is that he always the first one
[ __ ] myron uh smash
um
would this happen though and probably
not
like you know what i mean
um
let's see
uh entrepreneurs and cars
who's that entrepreneurs and cars you
don't know what that is
google em
where'd she go
[Music]
oh no gosh
torsha i miss you
oh my goodness
oh she's back next sentence
you're okay you're okay okay hold on oh
entrepreneurs and cars
rick rich cooper yeah rich cooper
he looks like my ex dude
like hardcore so i guess smash
really yeah a wide type okay
like you have a very let's see smash
your pass
you'll never know my type because i
don't even know my type
um
the lead attorney
what does he look like again the leader
um probably pass
pass
yeah pass
fresh
pass
um
which is funny because remember the one
time we played kill mary whatever
and i'm just like
smashing my guess
at the time
women
well it's all about what the other two
that you you put up you know i know i
know like that's not an experience
i know sometimes the red pill takes it
so seriously oh you're just like or just
doesn't get the actual video and thinks
that we actually want them
or even that
even
oh my god
i could not believe when i saw the thing
that was like they're arguing about who
gets to ask me i'm like that's how you
took the video well when somebody lives
in a delusion dude they make it fit your
narrative bro i was like
all the comments were like that's how
you took the video okay
i didn't even go back to the comments
since he deleted it he did yeah he
played that
yeah no [ __ ]
i didn't know he deleted it that's even
better that's hilarious yeah who else
um
donovan
smash
uh
you're just smashing everybody no i
passed on the last two
fresh and lead attorneys i know but for
the normal girl like you're saying smash
a lot more than when i like talk to
girls like it's usually like 10 maybe 20
no i'm like aware of what i might say
versus what i might do so i try to go
based off of what i would do
huh
okay
um okay kevin samuels smashing pass
i can't stop staring at that piece of
artwork on his desk with all due respect
it's not good for add okay and don't
even listen to this man speak i look at
this
thing that goes back and forth then the
next for sure
what do you mean
okay um
i knew you were gonna i don't know why
i've been asked that that was i don't
know either like he made my career
uh zooby
smash
i love him
[Music]
tuna okay thank you so much for the
super chat as you guys know all
donations are going towards the sound
board what am i doing with the sound
board okay
i'm going to get girls from all
different countries to come into my
apartment and we're going to talk about
different intersexual dynamics
so now i'm at 260 wait 367
out of my 500 goals
oh god no it would work that one woman
saved australia with
her nudes
i think part of the reason that i dress
modestly is because i don't have the
confidence to do like to do it the other
way
um pearl would you ever consider point
shaving
to help fund your youtube career what is
point shaving
it might be a brand
point i've had a few brands
reaching out and that sounds like
something they would say
yeah i don't know what that is well
donovan put it in the chat and i was
like i don't know what that means point
sharing
like point shift point shape i don't
yeah i don't know what that is
okay wait
um
okay what about o'shea duke jackson do
you know who that is yes
that sounds stupid
guys what is that guy's name um
i forget i for i always forget about
sabo
well because i only know him through you
uh what about chisha zad do you know who
that is who
she said
how do you it sounds like see it you
should cat
h i c h i s h a z e d
c h i
really
s h a z e d guys call in we'll rate you
smash your pass
shisha
said uh
i need more information
who is this man
he dislike i've been on his channel a
couple times oh he's really happy he's
real
i don't know i don't think he's a rapper
he's really nice hi
come on
he has an album
a rapper okay
oh i guess maybe he does all right
mediocre tutorials and reviews
is that a name
you don't know
you don't know who mtr is no he's not a
huge channel
you know this [ __ ] i don't know this
[ __ ] i'm tr
um yogurt
i don't know
pearl you have a youtube channel and you
don't know what point shaving is or
you're an athlete and you don't know
what point shaving is i don't know i'm
sorry
guys
all right google point shaving
an attempt as by member of the team
favor to win to influence the final
score of the game
oh so you pick somebody to win
so it's like a
i don't know okay but mediocre
what's the name
it says it means the game has been fixed
i don't know what that means um how
mediocre tutorials and reviews
john davis
uh
oh i'd have seen this guy hold on
or maybe i haven't uh
pass
pass
pass yeah did you
she she said smash your pass
uh
the the rapper dude that's all
yeah let me go back i have to look at
him again i think smash i'm not really
into
i see
like i need to know who they are
you know
like what if i'm
traitor
and by traitor i mean what if this is
somebody that like hates us
like you know like
oh i don't
like i mean hates like our channels or
something
like somebody that makes reviews or
something like i don't know well i don't
i don't think he i don't think he knows
what our channels are i'm going to be
honest
has he talked about this
no
like i don't call me that guy
had me on his channel i was like
what do you mean
like i was so scared and then i open it
and he's giving me a curse like this is
something that would make me not want to
smash you you see what i'm saying i
think that would be a deal like that
that guy is so weird he
follows me on like different accounts
and makes hate videos and i'm just like
give me more attention
i mean like i don't know it's worth
somebody into crystals or somebody that
like live streams
i don't know
zach you're gonna tell us what what
point shaving is
yeah i was surprised you didn't know
that because you used to play basketball
correct
yeah
okay so you're aware that people bet on
games right
yeah typically not women's games you
can't do a writing or anything on
youtube technically it's like
basketball games this has nothing to do
with youtube well
well donovan's comment was what i
consider point shaving for like the mic
so i was like i don't know what that
means
well okay let me explain well best i can
okay so people bet on the games and
sometimes people that bet on the games
they'll come up to a player and then be
like hey
i'll pay you x amount of money if you
underperform so i can so you can lose
this game so your team can lose
oh i would i do that um
at least i think that's what that was
going on there oh okay um it was a joke
i think okay yeah it looks like a joke
but
wait i don't get it i would just
you don't get it no
okay i'll explain it again is this about
the sound board
yeah it's not i guess it could be it's
just it's just it's about money so i
guess it's about the sound board
he's asking if i would if i would throw
my games basically for money
like that's what he was asking like i
think he was kidding
yeah i think that's what i got from it
yeah yeah
okay happy birthday
i appreciate it
um
but
anybody else in the youtube sphere is
that it
okay outside logan paul
uh pass
ksi
what the [ __ ] are these people dude you
don't know what ksi is he said no
whatever
ksi
like i already know it's going to be a
rapper
it's a rapper no
no he's a youtuber he might rap too i
don't know but he's a youtuber
uh
pass
um
i might just be doing that because both
of them box
it could be a factor i dated a ufc
player
um andrew tate
andrew tate who the [ __ ] is that why
can't i think of that right now he's a
youtuber he's a youtuber
he just did a video the one with
michaela smash for sure
love him really
yeah i like his vibe merch
dude i got so much hate on that video a
lot of people don't like him i didn't
know that oh because he's very
controversial
do you like that i reacted to a video of
him saying that he he throws a party to
how and cheats on his girlfriends in
front of each other and if if they're
not loyal to him
and he's like and if they're not loyal
then that's their fault
[Laughter]
i know he's religious
yeah like recently
[Laughter]
i mean
if you are
if you're
you practice
you know maybe like islam
something in islam then
i don't think in islam i don't think in
islam they tell you to throw up party
well they believe in polygamy
yeah but not like that they believe in
wives not [ __ ] like right in front of
each other right like but he he
seriously is religious no
okay
that's what i've heard
i don't know i believe that just as much
as i believe michaela's religious now
hasn't she always been
no
i thought she was that was what the
whole
how do you know i thought they were the
video she found god at like 29.
did she i don't know yes that's like
that's why rolo made the video about her
because she found god at 29 so that's
why he was using the example
i thought he was using the example
because of uh
leaving the baby daddy
well that too
i didn't know there was a god component
i don't remember
uh chase elliott do you know who that is
oh hold on i got my google up chase
the name sounds familiar ellie yet
nascar
or youtuber
um
daniel cormier
how do you spell the last name
c-o-r-m-i-e-r
if i drop a 500 super chat will i date
you
what it
got 1300
i'm not a prostitute no i love when
people would be annoying at the bar and
i'd be like okay 1300 for my troubles
they would
it's great
doesn't hurt to ask guys call in call in
and we will rate you
smash your pass so the dean from last
show that the first guy
um
that you get you said pass or smash and
i said pass because of the weight he's
working out
actually i think he sent me i was like
we want to update pictures i told him
he's getting back on in a month a month
and we're going to see if his score goes
up
oh my gosh that's so funny that's so
cool
did i not tell you that i told somebody
no you did you didn't tell me that did
you tell him i smashed him
on
i honestly i didn't say this but i think
you guys are gonna end up together
i see it
you see it yeah okay so
he was like hey it's dean hi dean by the
way he goes i really enjoyed being on
the show
a couple days ago he sent me this on
saturday um i think i really wanted to
underestimate how much my weight was
holding me back i set my intake for
losing two pounds a week um on lose it
thanks for the honesty it got me off my
ass and starting the process and i'm
just thinking to myself this is why i
love men because you guys have this
thing this software heart hardware
whatever you want to call it where if
you post something as a challenge as in
having to get laid
like going to the gym to get rid of your
man boobs is a lot more like that hits
closer than lose the weight right yeah
like because you want to have sex
and not have man boobs so like the thing
about men is you pose anything as a
challenge
and like as long as they've been in the
habit of some of something it could be
anything like work
they have it in them to like jump on
that like we don't really have that at
least nothing well because we we get we
get hurt we're like ah
like if somebody said you're a four
because you're too fat like we cry
right but they listen they say oh i can
be a nine if i just lose the weight yeah
that's it like yeah yeah and
i'm i'm like oh let's make this a
challenge again so then i'm like come
back in a month
see if your score goes up because he was
good looking dude he had the job
that's what i said i was like
like it's literally just your way to be
honest
i wouldn't look at him because of the
weight though and i'm not talking about
him as a person i want to be clear i'm
just saying when somebody is overweight
the reason i've never had really guys
that were overweight ask me is because
they're invisible to me
the only reason why i was like even
looking at him was because he called in
and i bet you a lot of women are like
that i just want
it's like come on you got it all
now allocated in all areas
yeah and that's the one thing you can
change like he had a good face like you
could tell he was cute oh yeah it was
just
literally the weight
and i was like even if you just got to
like 200 like 220 that would probably be
fine what's it yeah do you remember it
was like close i think it was over 300
to be honest i that might have been me
saints the new producer on freshman fix
i remember saying that he was at 397
and he's like working with uh myron he's
so he's so sweet you would be obsessed
with this guy
he's like smiling all the time totally
your type like positive
i see it
i don't know
wait who
new producer like another producer i'm
freshman
i glanced at it like it was
it popped up while i was uploading a
video and then i was like oh who's this
guy and he was introducing himself but
he was at 397 so i'm curious to see
his weight loss journey they're going to
check in like every week
huh
oh that's so cute actually
yeah like that'll be cute though to like
to have him come back like that's
adorable
oh hell yeah
better get your ass in the gym dean
we're going to be watching no i mean
that's what i always say when you get
rejected it's all about how you respond
it is all about how you respond because
like the way he responded and he wasn't
like butt hurt yeah like it makes you
more attracted to to the guy same with
the one who where i was like oh you're
too short for me but you're still like
like you're cute you're too short hold
on and he wouldn't like his name james
was it james i think it was james i'm
not a names person
because you don't care
there's a video on it that came off rude
there's a whole
uh what's that one youtube channel
called like
mindset something about
with tom billio sizing
quest bar guy
you know who i'm talking about stop
his sister has a channel and she
interviewed somebody who what's her name
quest what is it what do i have to
google tom billy tom b.i he talked to
michaela on that
episode where she was talking about her
daughter
remember that
yeah yeah
that's the guy tom bilio
anything someone someone's here but no
camera should i let him on oh nope he
left
he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
if you want to submit your instagrams
oh yeah you can put your
your instagrams in the chat i don't even
think about that you're smart
we should do truth or dare but they have
to pay
for yourself oh good idea good idea
so smart you dare me to do something
guys i'll do it okay
yeah the ten dollar super chat and
torsha will do
but nothing
you know the line i don't even have to
say what the line is we all know what
the line is
yeah we don't even have to one time
where you wanted me to call my dad and
everybody was like oh that was a low
blow because everybody knows my dad
but it was a good one because i didn't
want to do that
call him tell him i'm a stripper
oh my god i should call a strip club
hi
hey
i worked at one
strip club
for a minute in las vegas sapphire
have a bartender
well then they it was like my first day
and they're like oh yeah it's topless
and then in the
pool area and i was like oh so i went to
go change and i left
oh really
i couldn't but they apparently are the
top uh pool party makes sense i mean if
you have topless bartenders too [ __ ]
i couldn't i was terrified my hair
wasn't long like this was not good
i've only been to a strip club once
it was such a weird night
oh my god that was such a weird night i
ended up like making money and my friend
got offered a job but it wasn't for the
reasons you think
like no it's usually not it was like all
these guys like wanted
like us to put money on the strippers so
like what the f i'm gonna keep that like
what do you
you just gotta wear tape on your shoes
i didn't think about that i got arrested
for that i think it's actually they
check your shoes
i didn't know that oh my god this was
like years ago i haven't
and i did not enjoy that i was like i
don't know where to put my hands i don't
want a lap dance i just give the
stripper all the money that my boyfriend
gives me
he was mad we talked about chicken
nuggets
too soft
oh god
ah
what uh are pearl are you and torsion
going to back up
huh
never never mind i'm gonna ignore that
comment i shouldn't like read our
comments
i can't believe you stole from
hard-working women i didn't steal i was
given the money it's not my fault i
didn't choose to do what he wanted me to
do with it but it's not my fault
what did he want you to do with it
there's 63 people watching i know roll
roll up shout out rolo if you're
watching thank you so much because i
didn't i would not have this many people
here if you did not share that
um
oh i thought i thought he did i sent it
to him i don't know if he did
oh i thought right after you sent it to
him then like a bunch of people came on
so oh then maybe he did
not oh yeah he did he did he did
rolo said to come back
easy money
um
yeah you should do like uh bikini picks
ten dollars
bikini
just get us some wrong it's like the
thing you wrap around your waist
guys one piece
i just really don't like the idea of
like selling anything like well i don't
know that guys can like jerk off to you
oh yeah i forget that they do that to be
honest yeah
it goes right over my head
um
have you had any
trouble with your girlfriends over red
pill point of views um with my friends
it's like they just don't care and they
don't want to hear about it
what about you
my friends don't even talk about the
fact that i have a podcast for over a
year like they've never mentioned it
they don't share my [ __ ] like i don't
know
they don't really want to hear about how
we're approaching a wall and like most
girls just would rather have fun and not
think about
my girlfriend her
boyfriend watches my videos he's been
like in
red pills since before they started
dating and like i guess
she was bitching about him i was like
well just so you know or approach in the
wall
something to think about and sometimes
they made up
i just think it's funny but
it's like when do you draw the line i
don't know
i had a girl on my team who said we look
better as we get older i'm like
you're missing the point girlfriend it's
okay i no i was like you look i looked
at him like you're telling me you look
better now than you did in high school
i found out you came
all the time though
like i probably peaked in high school i
was probably one of the hotter ones and
then after high school i got hotter
i think at 25
i probably 25 26
peaked again and then now i'm not
i think that's as high as i go
i peaked at 19
yeah for sure okay
i don't think i look that crazy
different to be honest but i was just a
little i was just a little thinner to be
honest at 19.
i've always had
like a bony
face
and sometimes that's viewed attractive
and sometimes that's not like i don't
know it's like i have a strong jawline
most people
compliment me on it but like
statistically they prefer
more of like
i don't know a feminine jaw i don't know
well you you have a good smile i think
that's your most like prominent feature
to be honest really actually
yeah i think it's your teeth
really
yeah and you're fine so like it helps
well i mean i'm a girl so we look like i
look at you you complimented them you're
like with all due respect like you're
dude
i've never met anyone in person that has
that big of boobs
actually
i was like oh my god like i don't have
friends that like got boob jobs to be
honest like i don't know honestly they
look the same
like as my tits before so it's just
funny i always was the girl with boobs
so
i don't know
it just caught me off guard because i'm
shy
i know i'm like very like i don't know
why i just say what i'm thinking like
regardless regardless of the
consequences or what it makes the room
feel like i just say it
[Music]
oh man i remember i just think about
oh like the worst thing happened when i
was in florida for fresh and fit and
stuff and i was like oh my god i left my
makeup on the [ __ ]
airplane
and i was like this isn't good
so literally i had on
whatever i had on that day
i didn't have lashes on i was looking at
the video and i was like i look good
impression fit
i don't know so i go in between like
looking hot with less makeup and then
other days where i'm like i have to have
my cleopatra thing so i don't know if
it's an age thing i don't know
well it could be like is your skin
always clear or does it go through your
faces well phelan says that i have acne
and i don't
see acne on my face like i don't either
but she has this thing where like little
bumps could be
seen as acne i think she's an
esthetician no
like i wear sunscreen and powder
so
sometimes it like sits
top three features i notice on a man
one is height duh what about you
forearms back posture
in that order
height
uh smile probably eyes
depending on the guy whatever is nicer
if it's just my eyes are nicer i'll
notice that first then smile a lot of
girls say
teeth on a guy smile
and i never notice teeth and i know most
guys don't get their teeth fixed
it's more of a
if it is us like up the genders women
get their teeth done more
but like
but like
i i remember my ex told me he purposely
grew out a beard because he hated his
teeth and so i told guys if you have bad
teeth but you can grow a beard do it
like the long beard i don't like beards
yeah they're gross
i don't know but i think most girls do
i'm in the minority like most girls like
beards
yeah they're gross to me
but like i'll still date somebody that
has a i guess
i don't know it's hot and then it's not
i'm not very consistent
um sir what is your username
what's it say
i don't know what to say
okay if you're trolling get off like no
okay
okay turn if you want to come on turn
your camera on um
let me check
girls always compliment my smile but
rolo says it's more of a female trait
well i think i like profiles it is i i
think i like more feminine looking guys
like i don't when i when i looked at
that
there was a guy who broke down like
attractiveness into like more masculine
features and more feminine features and
like though i liked the guys that were
more feminine featured i don't know why
i think a lot of people forget that
like
feminine features on guys like what is
seen as more feminine or beta or
whatever somebody wants to say
it's going to be the opposite when
you're on birth control
so like not under control
okay so
for women that let's say
i see a guy that's feminine
he's
technically masculine
if she's on birth control oh really yeah
so and people think like oh if she's
technically ovulating
she would see it it's one of those
things that like still kind of confuses
me but i remember
brought it up in the episode with rolo
and she said
um i think it's a problem that women are
put on birth control at a young age and
they think they're attracted to one
thing get off birth control and then go
for the opposite
yeah
i don't know no i have like birth
control in years so
i like i've specifically stayed off of
it as much as i can to be honest i was
on it for a couple years but
i don't know
i was on and off of it for sure but
now that i don't have sex
i'm good
yeah almost
365 days
damn
not of choice
not him
georgia yes it is of choice no it's not
i'm just you know isolating
you know there's people that you could
sleep with if you wanted to sleep with
someone yeah but i don't i've never had
a one-night stand pearl i would have a
panic attack i know i know
i know but i'm saying that's a choice
i guess maybe not
you think
like you think you couldn't
well nobody hits me up
for sure
what do your dm's look like
[ __ ] empty maybe more today because
it's my birthday and people have been
sending me messages but usually empty
yeah see everybody is you can see some
sending me a birthday message i don't
know if you can see my phone's gonna die
hello
one of them's me
yeah
but everything's happy birthday but
before that like no
daddy ass
what people will send me things like
about the shower topic ideas or
something
oh my gosh do you know what i
felt like this dm i got today
look at this
this man
um
okay i just got a weird dm someone dm me
i told my parents about us
i don't know i know
for sure okay go with it what would you
normally say do a question mark i think
no this man has nothing like that oh
actually i shouldn't show his username
but like i'm either
send me their profile i'll tell you
where it is right now
you can
oh my gosh no um this guy
oh
yeah this guy has been sending me high
since like 2017.
are you going to respond yet
no
why not he's putting the work
um
my my instagram is just and then dot
pearly thanks i'll put in the chat
we should live stream i wish my like on
instagram too
i wish i knew where a charger was
you bumped the stream i know
thank you i never get this many people
in my lives
how many people are in thank you that
was so nice of you
um there's
somebody
oh no rolo put oh he's in there
yeah
baby daddy
okay give give me people to smash or
pass i'll do it too
uh
rolo
i think i've asked you that before i
think you said
you said pass
yeah pass
but but please but please but please
keep bumping the streets okay
don't don't get mad at her i'd get
pissed i probably didn't go up if you
said you would
to be honest
no one first
okay give me another give me another
pass
really
with
he has
too much of like um it's just not like
the like the look facially that i go for
like respectfully
no he's good looking i wouldn't want to
[ __ ] him and i said smash
so like you can't deny good genes
really you don't think he's no no i mean
i no he's not okay how do i put it like
he's not a bad looking guy he's just not
like
you like more feminine
i do i do like me a feminine like
looking guy i don't know
give me another lead attorney i would
say has feminine yeah
that would be like easy smash
yeah you love him
yeah i do he's so cute
he's good looking but i don't know i
can't smash or pass people i know
already okay give me people in the chat
no the manusphere what's his name the
guy that thinks that we want a bang
what's his name
johnson
the only reason he got the app he stupid
mary kill was because
of the other two people in it
no he's dumb and he was like oh these
girls are fighting over effing me i'm
like what the sir
when you live in a delusion long enough
you will change whatever a person says
okay kevin ray weinberg wilder
oh
kevin wait who's
i think i know who that is
is that the white pill guy because i
think i was on a live with him once
yeah where you want to go live with them
no no no no you've been on a live with
1400 legs it popped up in my [ __ ]
feet
oh that guy i went to that was the boot
camp i went to
okay wait i thought 1400 mlays was
guys what's his name lifestyle yeah
anthony i went to his boot camp that was
that video i did i thought that was
somebody else that guy looked like a
vampire that was a different dude
was it a boot camp i'm confused that was
his
the lead attorney is just the steve
harvey of youtube okay well
i accurately i i stand by what i said
she
to be honest i don't know why
um
andrew tate
um
i don't like his personality but he's
he's good looking so smash you don't
like his personality
no
i don't he's high energy i thought you
would
well it's more like i just don't like
the things that come out of his mouth
what is that
uh i don't know
what about dj academics
um
i forgot what he looks like hold on
i know i've seen him before but i've
never looked that close
uh
andrew probably probably smashed
um what andrew schultz
dad shoes
andrew schultz oh
probably smash
[Laughter]
trying to think of who else i don't know
you guys he's from the roommates oh my
gosh that is like
like top five on youtube smash easy i
think he's so really
yeah i think his co-host is cute i don't
know i think they're both cute oh my
gosh
uh
they're both good looking rolling look
at me justin waller let me see
[Laughter]
you know justin waller waller is he's
like the ginger archetype for me that's
what everyone says
oh him pass
um i'm just not he's tall
is he he doesn't look tall i don't look
at it
he's tall i've never seen him it's just
like a from a picture quick is it
because he's a ginger
he's a good [ __ ] dude i actually
think you would really like him i'm
surprised you said no
it's just
um
russell brand uh pass
what about you russell brand
yes maybe back in the day but now that
he's like a new woke boy no
like with all due respect i he's
catering to those people and that's
great he has a good way of
kind of favoring both sides when really
favoring
the wolf culture by
verbalizing it i don't know he's kind of
talks a lot and i talk a lot so i don't
i don't think it'd work
chris who else this is fun
tristan tate
um you look like
hold on tristan tate um
his name sounds like a cracker
it's andrew tate's brother i would do
smash yeah
wait but you don't like andrew no i said
i said like looks alone smash i just
don't like oh
so because i've heard him like talk it
would be like like why would i want to
sleep with the guy that says i want to f
like
people in front of their girlfriends
like that's weird when did he say that
it was a video i reacted to
that's crazy [ __ ] tate
oh my gosh there's so many charlemagne
the god smasher pass yes
uh looks alone smash but i i don't know
after like that thing he was involved in
that was weird
um
like the underage girl
yeah
yes somebody was on their show that was
gonna come on my show talk about crypto
some episode
lebron james
pass sorry guys i know you guys like
sports
[Laughter]
everyone i would smash is maybe like
steve nash or something
i would smash still brian james drake
kanye
uh
pass pass
actually maybe kanye only because i'd
want him to like fix me up he made kim
you know he really elevated her i could
use it
i actually think i would date kanye
you would date kanye's too short for me
like five eight i think
five seven
um
sterling cooper
uh
probably
oh
i probably would if i didn't know that
he was a porn star
[Laughter]
so no i don't know i don't know who that
is
look him up he's got a pretty popular
channel pass
uh richie cooper pass i'm not i don't
he looks like my ex like i can't even
lie which cooper is like
he's not bad looking it's just like my
preference isn't the age gap thing
that's like not
but let's say you could only look at
them
wait age gap thing
like i i'm not
like a lead attorney is old i know but
he doesn't look old
but i think i don't think rich looks
that old either
does he
i'm like trying to not be rude yeah i
don't know are you being rude i don't
think it's rude
hi
hello we can't see you sir get in the
light
oh sorry about that
no you're fine how are you
thank you
what are you up to
what are you doing
i'm just sitting around
sitting around doing white what's your
name
uh my name is kyle
kyle nice to meet you
what are you doing to torsha
and waiting for a living
uh
well i do
i do independent i.t work i'm also have
recently started
supplementing my income doing door dash
like that's my time being
their ads always come up on my tick tock
apparently it's fun to work for them
is it true
is it fun
uh
well well it's certainly the easiest
thing i've ever done
really
i don't have the balls to do that to be
honest with you
that terrifies me all the interactions i
couldn't good for you
oh i have to about you i don't even have
to interact
that most of the time i'm just dropping
stuff at the doors
nice now because of coved right
yeah
yeah that's awesome actually now you're
making me want to do it because i'm
broke as [ __ ]
okay
uh
sadly i didn't luck out on the height
thing but uh um average height like
around 5 10 but in my defense i starve
myself in my teens to get my weight down
how much do you weigh
uh unfortunately i packed on pounds
again during cove for the first time but
i
sadly i was obese as a child
ah i'm so sorry you don't look obese i
can't really see you but you don't look
yeah in the in the face i look thinner
yeah yeah i can't say
510 is taller than average isn't it or
is that yeah that's that's like about an
average for a guy yeah that's beautiful
yeah
let's see didn't luck
you're in the clear
yeah that's good for most girls or five
five so hate-wise
yeah
this guy's good looking
thank you
you're welcome do i make you
uncomfortable sorry
no not at all when i laugh i'm laughing
at pearl
not you i'm just awkward so i laugh like
myself just so we're clear everybody so
you're 5 10 you have two jobs how old
are you
i'm 32.
i'd smash
probably give you like uh
probably
a six
yeah i'm a six you're a six
we're all sixes
[Laughter]
girls
uh i would do pass
you i'm a height person yeah yeah what's
that six nine kind of
me i don't mind
oh thanks for coming up
[Laughter]
no i'm trying to like there's another
person here i just want to keep them
waiting too long i know
um
hi
we can't hear you yeah i can't hear you
do you have your headphones plugged in
yeah i just muted myself uh what's up i
actually don't really know what's going
on i decided to hop on so um
yeah oh we're doing smash or pass do you
want to smash your past
like who though
you
you do you want us to we don't have to
do it if you don't want yeah otherwise
what do you first notice about a girl
on the spot
pearl is there more people
honestly wait like just to keep
wait really
yeah i think that's most guys they
forget to say that
i mean it's like hey you know everyone
everyone should get love but you know
certain people doesn't have to be me
a lot of guys and i was watching a lot
of fat girl got skinny videos on tick
tock and they were saying that guys
wouldn't even speak to them because they
were fat
i was like no [ __ ] dude so i tweeted
that i'm new to tweeting but like
yeah i tweeted that and a lot of guys
liked it they're like yeah we ignore
them so they don't know that we like
them
yeah i mean i guess if i'm like really
like the
like three times a year i'm in a club if
i'm like really got my eyes on someone
i'm you know
not gonna really be going for someone
who's overweight
but i mean i actually heard like a good
part of like game or just being sociable
in general is like make sure
not to like a large extent but like if
you're approaching like a
group of women like talk to everyone
don't just like hyper focus like one
person
you usually want to focus on the mom who
is usually the fat one and if you can
get her approval the mom of the group we
call them the ones that are
like
not like like actual bills but if you
can get their approval then you're in
the clear and they're usually very easy
to get approved because they don't get
approached often
yeah that's that's also one thing it's
like you know when you date someone you
also have to date their friends
i've never heard that but i love that
it's a good because we want guys that
other women like
like we want we want i don't know yeah
like
yeah but typically like we want we want
someone that with like social status and
that's one way to show it is if her
friend's like oh then yeah
that's a way to yeah
yeah like that's what like you want to
date you want to date someone that
people like i mean my girlfriend always
hated my boyfriends
oh [ __ ] yeah so that's funny
that ended up [ __ ] i wish
someone and then i kind of realized our
friends are [ __ ] annoying so i quit
doing it
my friends are pretty easy to get along
with i think
but they'll talk [ __ ] about you behind
your back
yeah so just when you think you're in
the clear you're uh yeah y'all stay
doing that it's like you know just
live my life and then rumors come around
and so
i'm going after talking about me saying
xyz i'm like
what
i think guys talk to their guy friends
about girl problems more than girls
actually go to their girlfriends
to be quite frank with you i can't
refute because i'm you know
maybe that's the problem i don't really
hang out with a lot of women so it's
like i'm just stuck doing my own thing
um
i meant dudes like you would like if you
and pearl were dating and you guys were
fighting or something
you are more inclined supposedly to go
to your guy friends for advice than
girls are to go to their girlfriends
because girls just don't even want to
tell their friends or get it's kind of
like telling your mom
once she knows your phone
it's because yeah it's because it's like
you want the girl we don't want the
girls to like
know later
you know like if you tell if i tell
torso like i'll never forget he did he
did this this this this and this and
later yeah we're like
actually but i still do so i don't i
know it's like telling your mom like
once you tell your mom you're [ __ ] you
know once your mom knows about justin
bieber said it the best and my mama
don't like you and she likes everyone
yeah
usually
yeah
i've been talking with like uh my guys
about like you know how how it is for us
reason i just wanted like a lot of like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like
one of my my old roommate just like
cocked one of my friends just like jesus
[ __ ] christ we cooked yeah like which
yeah i
slept without uh other friends
girlfriend i'm like
bruh oh no
i don't mess with that like that's
[ __ ] up yeah and if they were just all
like oh we're you know we're all drunk
and i was like
i don't know i don't i don't personally
like i don't drink anymore so it's kind
of easy for me to say but yeah
hey sometimes people it's about it
some people do black out
yeah like hardcore especially like it's
bad it's all in college so it's like i
mean
yeah at a let's say just out of school
that's uh won a pretty big game recently
so you know
our
downtown on any given down uh any um
weekend it's like
partying all my friends are getting out
and just getting blasted so it's kind of
like the it's different yeah yeah did
she say how old am i but yeah but okay
i'm 22.
okay so i actually have to try to
remember my birthday is it's okay i
forget to
like honestly when people ask me my age
i'm like 23 and then i'm like oh [ __ ] i
forgot old enough like
yeah
okay
i don't know what else to ask pearl
i feel like i know all the answers
matt calls well this is smasher pass um
did anybody call in
yeah i haven't i have a do you want to
be smashed or passed or no because if
not i'm going to go to the next person
uh
sure i mean i don't i'm just hopping i
don't really care
okay
smash your pass uh
how tall are you
uh
what do you say
oh you're like a [ __ ] tree
yeah fair enough i got you short man
i saved the tall ones
i don't i don't work out so like [ __ ]
it doesn't matter the tall ones should
be with the tall girls that's what
that's always kind of my thing you guys
need to reproduce oh wait wait wait when
you said i'm a tree is that because of
height or is it like i'm also skinny
trees aren't always skinny
i don't
no you're fine
i'm too tall though i'd have to like
look up [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah that's one thing i never got it was
like you know like oh i'm just like
swiping on board i'm like oh you know i
want a guy who's like six blah blah blah
six six two six four that's why guys
they're like they're like six one i
don't know like not six one like five
one i'm like bro like
i'm here you would be like here how does
that work
that's funny i always forget you're so
short
thanks for calling in appreciate it
no problem
you didn't play
oh i forgot
um
hello
how you doing pearl how are you doing
torture how's it going
good good how are you
uh this guy done working out and just
freaking practiced in my japanese so
it's quite fine
how's your japanese kenichiwa
konichiwa
wow
yeah are you saying
my name is
yes
that's really good
dang okay japanese is hard i think it's
hard no it's easy for me at least for at
least for me like i said standing isn't
a problem i tell people it's
understanding the kanji in the harry
gotten kind of
down yeah now when you speak in a full
sentence that's uh
says you i think it's hard well yeah it
says me i guess
i mean it doesn't come easy for
everybody you have to understand that so
that's why i don't flaunt it or quoted
i'm just like i guess they're just easy
for me i don't know yeah i love japanese
i just said words
yeah
yeah pearl does too don't you love
japanese
yeah she laughs
when i was a kid oh she's laughing
no no because torsion knows the back
story
i know about the kimono i had a very
weird
phase um
i don't like to talk about it um anyways
moving on
every everybody's beautiful
yeah every girl wants to experience that
one time so i can't deny it yeah that's
yeah that's what it was one time
okay moving on
okay
okay um you want you call in to be
smashed or passed
you could be either
okay i'm just here
okay how tall are you
i am six zero
i look short guys
say that again one more time i like more
than the size of jockeys
you know she's only five one she doesn't
like them too tall
i like them smarter than me
that make a lot of money
you like him shorter than you okay okay
like the horse
no no i know what you mean but don't
worry i'll answer that as soon as we get
to asking pronouns questions and i'm
going to get to that in a second because
she stumbled upon an interesting thing
for me to talk about but but um what i
do in my spirit not in my spare time but
what i do is job i work two dubs i do
delivery and then i do pressure washing
and i make like at least 10k at least
yeah and it's a lot of it's a lot of
work while trying to do youtube i put
out videos too but oh no like i said i
keep myself busy a lot
how old are you
i am free
your wife i'm 30. yeah and i don't look
at you
oh i was like you i thought you were
going to be like 22 or 23.
yeah i don't like it i know i don't i
got some good genes
black people they always look [ __ ]
younger blessed
they do
i used to be a maker
not all of us but i haven't met one
and i live in chicago y'all always look
young baby faceless blessed seriously
yeah that's very true
i'm wise i haven't met one that i was
like she aged poorly not one or him
no though i i do know some people but
it's only because they're overweight i i
can't i could think of a couple but it's
only because they're overweight
maybe wait i could see that actually
um
maybe yeah i guess it depends where
you've uh
i said i guess it depends on where
you're at
because i know everybody in certain
places they look a lot more different
than as opposed if you were like in
california as opposed to miami
yeah
i live in chicago and
oh how did this person it's cold
that's cool what did this person this
person took my profile picture and my
username i'm so confused
wait be careful with that what are you
talking about
lemonade bag cut it out
you can do me but don't do her
it's it's just um
crazy
i'm assuming it's lemonade
um
let's see i'm trying to think of any
other questions so you're six foot
you have a good job
i would do
smash is somebody just like yeah
too tall
i'm just kidding
are you actually wait wait are you going
to vote for him
the question is are you actually six
foot or do you just say yeah go to a
door
[Laughter]
i can't see him oh look well you can't
actually steamboat on hold on let me see
if you guys actually see him want to
stand up
did you actually see him that's so funny
you ever you ever go on lives
okay he looks tall
that's actually funny i've never
actually had to stand behind my freaking
door before but
yeah oh he's us
make him do whatever
we have the same backdrop
oh nice
yeah
oh hold on i got like freaking like blue
lights and freaking things up in here so
so yeah people can see my art
oh you draw
um i do graphic design here and there
i've
done any big projects for like two
months
nice
well i'm keeping myself busy guys i
don't have time to do anything people
people are trying to get me to do
something guys i need i need like maybe
like a week off so i can do a project
for you or something
because i'm just too busy
your friends just try to use you is that
what i'm hearing no no no they don't try
to use me there's a difference i use
them well they try
but they don't
no no no because i'm just more uh able
to get the job done and probably do it
the way that they want they want it done
yeah and if not then i told them like
listen up chris
if i'm unavailable hit up my brother
chris you can do it he's got more time
tonight
uh i think he
does i don't know i reposted his stuff
and i tagged rolo and brolo shared it
because it was insane rolo always shares
my stuff
shout out
i need to get like you my boy roloff
shared one of my videos and it got so
many views i was like yeah not all
heroes wear capes but dude this artist
was he does like the what do you call it
cartoon
whoa i can't even think anime anime
yeah and it was insane
i wanna see if i can find it i was like
dude
i love graphic design and artists and
stuff
trust me that's where the money's at i
tell people especially if you're artists
you're more likely want to get married
to a female artist
man at least at least if you've been in
the field
because i've only run into like a
handful of um
female artists that actually been
portraits similar to me
and i've dated like one or two of them
and they're pretty much and they were
really artistic
i think youtubers would be compatible
with art artists
but that might be the opportunistic side
of me
i mean
like with all of you
i mean i make my own stuff well i think
it's because youtubers tend to be like
high energy yeah yeah and like we're
talkers that's why i think they go well
together
yeah
but i'm gonna i'm gonna get yeah you
need a profile probably for that like
you know to posterize yourself and you
know just merchandise yourself yeah like
i need a kanye west
you know
okay
i'm good now okay
thanks thanks for calling in
you're welcome girl sounds so rude when
she hangs up it's funny though no
because i'll try to like rest just leave
you just hang up on them that's all they
won't be mad
it's just like i'm trying to go not to
the next person but i want to go there's
more people
no no no there's not but i'm saying like
i want to do the ones that people are
putting in the chat okay make sense yeah
um
guys just so you know if you guys are
enjoying the stream feel free to donate
for the sound board that i'm saving for
i'm at
365
67 dollars i got two dollars let me do
this okay
if there are men out there sugar daddies
splendor daddies or just a man with some
ends
sponsor a bad [ __ ] she's trying to get
a sound board so that she can do videos
with a bunch of other [ __ ]
hot [ __ ] please donate somebody want
to carry this team and donate the last
150
anybody
takers
they're all athletes female athletes oh
my god i don't even think about playing
the hot card
yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing oh my gosh i
didn't even think about it i was like
we're all so fun you want a bunch of
girls on the video
[Laughter]
come on who's gonna finish it off you
guys get paid more per dollar
help your girl out
if you are in a stem career
thank you
that's a working if i throw 150
can i get that date that's a lemonade
bag keeps putting it yeah
just saying yeah
why wouldn't you
but are you gonna cover the expenses
lemonade
come on
do it
do it
she might get her boobs done too
okay i'm gonna add the next person
i'm not looking every dollar counts even
if it's just two dollars
hi
hello there
how are you
i'm good
about yourself
i'm good
about you georgia i'm kidding they're
just not saying anything
i'm good i'm listening i feel like i've
been talking a lot
so i'm gonna shut up it was a little bit
too much
yeah
um so where are you from
cold cold place called michigan oh yeah
okay
yeah yeah you inside right you know that
[ __ ] zoom
yeah it's [ __ ] cold
i wouldn't call where me and torches
from
me and torso are from chiraq
well they used to call it that i work in
this thing
yeah you know you go there for the food
get shot it's like a saying
sounds bad
it's like a chicago line i'm just saying
if it gets [ __ ] hilarious but
you know whatever
you ever seen any rappers out there
no i know some i know like chants and
[ __ ]
you know chance we talked about this
yeah
get him get him on my channel please
oh wow
that's a cool dude i'm sure he would
just ask him
you're like no
no i'm saying like how
she's
he uses his stuff like his instagram and
stuff
his entourage is pretty cool too
probably the only entourage that i
i'm cool with
next time i'm in chicago i might
yeah
wakka flaka was cool t.i was cool
g-eazy was weird
sorry
oh g-eazy he's [ __ ] worried
he hurt his music i thought he was black
i'm not even gonna lie
yeah he sounded black
i'm just saying to like i think a lot of
people thought that because normally
when you hear a white rapper they would
sound like eminem like wit lori do you
know who i'm talking about he sounds
like eminem he's a white rapper
but
yeah he does
you know i thought he was gonna be
really cool and he just was really
really strange strange dude
not a fan
yeah
i don't know
i could bad times
can i guess your age
that's why you're drawn to a lot of
people a lot of people get it wrong i
was wrong
23.
uh
25 that's wrong
wait hold up
let me do this hold on stand up
wait wait hold on stop it everyone shut
up a hundred and fifty dollars
oh
sorry thank you so much that is the
biggest donation i've ever gotten on the
screen
oh how do i do it all right
right that's a dollar sign
am i tripping that's a dollar sign
sometime one time it was japanese
currency
yeah that's like about 78 cents to the
dollar or something like that oh my god
but this isn't right i'm not tripping i
don't want to get too excited
thank you very much
thank you
guys just love to hear you thank them
not all heroes wear capes
sugar daddy in the house oh my gosh i'm
so excited yay she gets to get her thing
now
okay
i mean yeah that's why you want it right
okay stand up let me see
you gotta be 21
21 uh close i'm not there yet yeah
you're young 20. i do you at the bar
for sure
you all got to do all that
i'm a bartender
i'd want to know your address i'm
kidding i love using that line
that's a little creepy
is it though guys love it
and they're like really you're going to
id me and not my friend i'm like i just
want your address
the only reason i said 25 is because you
said that i would get it wrong so i
thought you were older than like you
looked but like the the jerseys on the
wall i was like he's got to be young
he's got to be in college
it's a term that
not a lot of people know called black
don't crack
so i don't know that's that's probably
what videos
wait what is that
blind bag crack
i've never heard that
you never heard of it no
really really
this must be too black then oh man
what is this thank you for the donation
chosen
152.
oh look
oh look more people donating bless them
thank you to all the mans out there
you're all right
miles also the next thing i'm going to
be fundraising for is a microphone for
the hot [ __ ] so just you know the
next thing anyways
what
said you're really going through with
this podcast idea
yeah i just think i have girls on my
team like from japan germany like all
over the world so i think it'd be really
cool to get them in here and have
something set up where i could do a live
show
yeah broadcaster is that what you're
getting i'm assuming yeah yeah yeah
because that is the most outlet
yeah i wanna i just
yeah
um what are you so you're in michigan
are you in school
yeah how old are you show me your idea i
feel like this is wrong whoa whoa whoa
let me see your id
let me see your id
ain't nothing going to happen online
saying anything
why are you telling me no i'm not going
to raise your ass
i'm over at age 18
let me see your id
he's [ __ ] trippin
you're not you're not 18. okay i'm
saving me and pearl from this one
17 year old boy if you remember my own
show
it's still wrong
17 about a year ago
whatever mm-hmm i don't believe you i
don't believe you don't believe me would
you really want to see my id that bad
yeah yeah not gonna happen
yeah my he's gotta be young
all right sorry miss my surprise
oh no we can't if i don't i gotta know
that you're 18. i don't even know i just
said
you're naughty i know but i need
my black don't crack that bad
i don't know what that means
what does that mean alex donovan i tell
you
donovan what's this mean
nice try though okay i appreciate that
you wanted us to guess okay that gave us
the hint look i got it right here i got
it right here
don't worry about the picture how was uh
taking this picture
yeah let me see let me see if this is a
fake okay it's standing upright
is it expired it's expired i just got it
let me see bring it all the way to you
really want to see my address not bad
no
hide that [ __ ]
expired 11
10 25 25 is when it expires it's hard to
read it's fake 11 24 no uh
10 31 25.
when were you born i didn't see anything
in the night
that's actually a crazy fact about going
to halloween oh no [ __ ] that's awesome
not really it's a blessing in the curse
i get called the devil's
strategy girls
oh yeah that's true
so it is it is what it is yeah that is a
thing if you guys want to get a girl to
really think that
y'all are serious text her at 11 11
she'll think it's because of her
crystals
[Laughter]
dang it yeah you got to first establish
something
i believe you that you're 20. i believe
it i don't believe him dude his idea is
vertical
that that's what they're like they're
like that in michigan my friend's from
michigan they you know
well you think he's 21.
[ __ ] no i think he's 20. he said 20.
i'll say i've never heard him give a
number
i don't believe him you can read him i
won't
it's not illegal at least here
all gets arrested
now i'm
[Music]
i'm too trusting oh no oh yeah you're
like i believe i was like no okay we are
not getting a restaurant oh no
as soon as he switched it i was like oh
i'm very glad that i haven't seen her
because i would have just believed him
he said okay okay i'm 18. i was like oh
yeah no he's not
i'm too trusting i just like believe
people
yeah no
don't do that
you're welcome
okay um
let's see what other names people put in
the chat
i love how you just keep nick up on the
screen
oh my god
daddy right now
like
thank you sir
i
[Music]
nobody thinks my ass like
okay okay for the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's true thank you torsha
i've been saying i'm
doing this at the bar and people are
like they didn't tip me i'm like hold my
beer
um okay i'm like
i'm like you forgot to tip me and then
they tip
i just stand in front of them when i
hand the receipt now i don't [ __ ] around
getting too old like i'm not going to
let you get away from not dipping
i'm trying to go up in the chat because
people are putting
okay marty you need to put your camera
on
uh
marty the troll
yeah he's not gonna put his camera on i
know
oh
okay though who is he actually you can
look people up right no there's a hole
on my channel
why did somebody do something mean to
you
no
oh yeah wait
different
i'm sorry
let's see
hey
[Music]
i'm like scrolling up
guys put names of people we should smash
or pass
your cash off money cash at monitor says
no results it's hannah pearl davis
that's my cash app
um
i actually think i have one that's just
pearly thing someone paid me on it the
other day
and i was like oh i forgot i made a
second cash up a while ago because i
forgot i had one
so it's actually just pearly things too
um
[Music]
and it'll it'll say hannah davis is the
name
i forget your name's hannah
i'm just like hey
someone paid me on it the other day let
me look it up and double check
um
i'm doing my first one-on-one
one-on-one coaching yeah yeah
nice
yeah i was
people were asking me in the comments so
i was like okay
um
let's see
[Music]
hold on let me find it
i know he sent me a screenshot
oh the receipt okay um
yeah it's just pearly things that's the
that's the other so you don't put
comments on the screen hold on i'm
reading
aaron clary
aaron clary mm-hmm
j-mac get out of here that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what
keep pearl off oh they really did make
my thing
you have a lot of trolls in here same
trolls
who's aaron clary i don't know who that
is rule zero
you know
rule zero is that what i should google
pool zero
aaron clary
no i don't i don't see anything
i don't know
how do you spell clary
c l
a r e
oh that is not
i would read that claire
that's how
this is a girl
no aaron claire he's a boy
he's a man
oh my gosh it's not coming
ryan who
i love this man what's his name hold on
the canadian guy
ryan stone
ross
the guy that's going the guy that's
going to jail
there's a guy going to jail i'm go i'm
just typing these into google oh no
flip the a and the i with ryan
there's an i in ryan
r
a i n
oh gosh
i've never seen it spelled like that
like rain
[Laughter]
yeah wait
is that how you spell it wait
r-i-a-n sorry did i flip it
oh him
all
right
yeah he's a
a pass youtuber
who else
i've said a lot of people i think i did
joe biden
i don't take advantage of men that
aren't mentally there
i would smash a young joe biden
he's not bad looking when he was younger
yeah when he was younger
somebody was not mentally like they
don't even have the capacity to consent
this isn't this isn't right there's
capacity and then there's competency so
in
law
in order for somebody to be deemed
like full capacity in or i'm sorry
capacity is in the hospital so somebody
who has like dementia they don't you do
not meet
they are not fully capable to make their
own decision so i'm gonna have to pass
i feel like that would be
wrong what about trump
pass
a young trump i would smash he was so
good i don't know when he was younger
now he looks like
orange have a thing for a narcissist
no
i'm not hating on them
ethan klein
who
ethan klein pass for me yes
king vaughn
only because i'm not trying to get
caught in the crossfire and like he he
died but no
he's a rapper
yeah
he was cute but i'm not trying to when
did he die rest in peace i'm not gonna
rape the
dead um
connor sully
smash
the guy on the bachelor that's who i
googled i don't have a tv how do you
spell sally
e-e-l-l-y
hockey player s-s-a-e
oh bye
i'm like
sally
i'm gonna say pass
um
[Music]
who is the one the best looking
celebrity you would risk it all for
risk it all is and go to jail
no i'm just like shoot
sorry to call her
[Laughter]
who i would risk it all for
a celebrity that i would risk it all for
what do you mean
what's that mean like like your number
one celebrity crush basically
it's just like another ben stiller
it's not good looking in seth rogen
wait what
i don't know it was my first sex dream
zooby actually
shut up that is like my number somebody
tagged him
that's my number one celebrity crush
wait really
not like just like overall like what
happened as a person i think he's so
fine like i i had him on my channel once
yeah and i was like so nervous because i
was like you were too fine to be here
it is so nice yeah
um
who else
alex from playing with fire
really
i mean that with respect i didn't think
he was your type
oh no i that was the next one
like i was asking oh oh somebody in the
chat oh you you asked another celebrity
um
i mean too i thought you were gonna name
too um
i want to say jesse williams but i
really after i've heard him talk enough
i'm like i think he's like the best
looking celebrity
jesse williams
um he's on grey's anatomy the mixed guy
oh i do know who they he's so hot but i
i've heard him talk too much and he's a
little too um i heard you said dick
yeah that's that's i'm not
but like looks like leonardo
young now
it's a thing
for me
i see you with justin i think you would
work it out with him
with who tristan thompson
he's good looking
look him up oh oh you mean i that was in
my youtube video that was the clip
what
tristan
tristan thompson yeah i think he's good
looking i think oh he's he's
he's good looking i wouldn't want to
date someone with three baby mamas
though
i think you'd risk it all for him
no no no no or no
would you be another one of his baby
mamas
no no i think he's so
i don't think he's uh ben shapiro smash
smash for sure
yeah
logan paul
smash no
you wouldn't have been doing it for me
no and that's weird because
the
looks wise
i dated anybody that looks like him no
i don't know what it is
it has to be look-wise
because personality-wise i think he's
great to be honest with you i think
somebody that can go through what he
went through
make mistakes that he made and then turn
it all around like to come up from
having such a poor reputation
right he was like
horrible
i don't think he's all there i think
he's a little
dumb
i don't know but like
that makes me find him attractive being
able to flip it like that but like looks
wise or something about him i just don't
want to look at him
maybe if i had a bag over my head
i don't know he's like gotten jacked to
be honest
i don't know i think he i think he's
cute i think he looks like
i think that's what it is
there's a thing
sorry go ahead keep going
shut up
you know who king batch is
is this a rapper
no i don't know i'm gonna google them
king ach
david gilmore when he was young oh smash
he's cute
king batch who
oh i'm talking about david gilmour
david david gilmore
yeah
a young one young okay i need to see him
young because he's you would love him i
think i think he would
smash yeah yeah i'm not a fan of the
hair
cobain but like clean
pete davidson smash easy smash i've been
saying it's unstable easy that's like my
skinny white boy type exactly i'm gk
no not mgk i passed the fdk
i've won
for a while
i don't know why
i would for sure
okay what about
i think i might change my mind tomorrow
what about um
king batch is 5a oh i take it back
i don't know who that is what about
playing with fire alex you didn't answer
oh path
what about um
john anthony lifestyle pass
they're not they're not really my type
right
um
who else is popular who pops up on vid
iq tags that's what i'm trying to think
of
donovan you never answered that
donovan always pops up for me donovan oh
that's a good question um
[Music]
shouldn't be that long
how old is he
doesn't matter
it does to me i don't know um probably
smash yeah
like i just feel weird because i love um
i love his girlfriend so i feel weird
like saying that
but no he's attractive you know i forgot
um
she's wifey
no she's so much wifey she's like so
nice i literally love her
um hussein [ __ ]
who do you know who that is h-a-s-a-n
[ __ ]
hey
we do that
is the last name good i've seen
[ __ ] oh he's cute um
smash he looks like a dog
no i don't know i don't know who he is
really i think he's cute i think he's
cute
he's a streamer he's a left-winger uh
well that's fine
columnist
is he turkish
yeah maybe um
maybe i'd have to see him in person he's
he looks like a somebody i wouldn't be
into
but maybe in person he looks different
guys look different in photos
well and so much with guys it's very
much like
you could be attractive enough to smash
but if you like
if you talk too much you can ruin it
like quite easy
i like awkward dudes
like nerdy ones
that talk
either too much or not enough
like i don't like the in-betweeners
i like either a guy that's as high
energy as me and we can like banter with
or
a guy that doesn't talk and just lets me
go off
like
one or the other yeah that's what i'm
saying like no in between well like you
like the uh
one that's
more normal not
too high energy right
i don't know i like the funny guy i like
the class clown
yeah
or the guy that's just like high energy
and easy to talk to
um
yeah or the guy that just like doesn't
talk at all and lets me
just like say whatever i want i like
barely listen
the one that you know doesn't get hit on
it's like one of my favorite things
what is it rich men will pay money for
pearl's little clam i like don't know
how i feel about that comment
like like a hooker like a hooker
how do you why are you allowing this
nonsense it's donovan
what did he say
it's not is it really him that doesn't
sound like something he would say
oh you're right it's probably a fake one
yeah that's weird
you're right you're right you're right
guys
um
it's out of pocket
okay it's 7 20.
okay okay
[Laughter]
yeah
oh god
anyways um
okay guys thank you so much for the
donations i appreciate it torsha thank
you for coming out on your birthday oh
you did not have to do that at all
oh yeah i got you
i always show up i might be late when i
show up
thank you for having me
okay thank you for the donation nick you
are thank you person on the planet
um
and i will talk to you guys don't forget
to subscribe i'll talk to you guys later
bye